ااا اليوم منذر رياحنا ايش وداك ليبيا يا
منذر الناس تقول والله خطر وانت رايح تصور
خريبي ليش شو اللي دفعك للمجازه
احنا بنقاوي
بمهنتنا اااه ليبيا ارض سيدي عمر المختار
قبل الشهداء فات بحس انه من واجبنا ان
نقدم نقدم شيء همم دليل يا اولاد
في ظل الاشياء اللي قدموها لنا
ليبيا جميله لا تستحق الا الجمال
وحسيت واجب انه الفنان يحارب بمادته وكنت
مبسوط جدا
من حيث التجربه العظيمه جدا اييه
ورجعت منتصرا من ليبيا عشان اهل ليبيا
قدموا عمل رائع بيننا فيه انجازات
لانه الفيلم الثاني فقط بعد عمر المختار
يكون الانتاج الليبي 100%
يعني ان شاء الله كمان يتقدم في عده
مهرجانات يقدم الفيلم الاول باذن الله في
المهرجانات العالميه دائما نحنا بنحكي لا
ننتمي الى السلاح ننتمي الى الكلمه ولكن
هم اجبرونا
متخلفين والدواعش
حكايه انسانيه
بطوله مجموعه كبيره من النجوم كلنا
متحمسين
جداول
بمشروع بناء من جوانب مختلفه واظن نحن بس
احسن من الشهداء اللي قدمه في سبيل الوطن